I kept conspicuously few notes and if
you watch the movie you will understand
that that is totally consistent with my
performance what do you mean your
performance is great in that
what yeah no like you've seen a
babysitter's Club oh I haven't seen that
one yeah exactly it's that's not a good
movie thank you Ryan knows Ryan have you
seen it I don't think so that's from
nine that's fine the demo it's fine how
old are you man 34. okay
you had to be there
can you tell us about the audition
process for the babysitter's Club did
you audition for other parts in that
movie also
that's a very smart question I'm
impressed that people know that and yeah
I think all of us sort of auditioned for
different roles so for him
um I auditioned for Marianne and Christy
we talked about how you love the
babysitters so just jump in and eat it
uh yeah and I did not find out if I got
the part of Marianne for a very long
time because they were looking to cast
the role of Christy who's a more Central
character to the to the piece gotcha so
the audition process was
um I just I walked into a room did my
best I guess it worked out maybe no one
else auditioned because I am not great
in that movie I every honestly kind of
dumb I was terrible was it 47 years ago
don't understand the stakes of Any Given
scene like it is it's it's pretty uneven
performance I can't look I gotta look
back and just smile smile at yourself
you know I'm being random myself we got
attacked robot about